I
Welcome everyone. My name is Janine
My pronouns are she her I want to welcome you to the table today
Thank you. All you folks online for coming and being with us have a couple of announcements for y'all
First of all on Friday, January the 23rd, we are going to have a game night
so it's going to be in the Family Life Center, which is back here on the back of the property and
We would just love for you to bring a game or a dessert because there is going to be a pasta bar
Awesome, who doesn't love some pasta?
and we are so grateful for this wonderful chance to
Connect and have deeper connections with our community
Also, we need to remind you that on Super Bowl Sunday in order for everybody to be able to do everything that they need to
Do that day we are going to bump the service up to 3.30
So that is February the 8th
services begin at 3.30
All right
I know sometimes it can be hard to walk in the church. Sometimes it may be that your
inner self is just anxious or fidgety and
so in order to accommodate those who may need it we have a
Accessibility bucket, it's the black one over there on the little table
And it has noise cancelling headphones and different things that you can fidget around with or you can color draw
Whatever might make you feel
much more comfortable here
The candles that I have lit are
Representative of Christ among us
fully human and fully divine
So
Now
let's exit the kingdom of noise and hurry and
productivity and
let's enter the kingdom of
silence and stillness and
simplicity a
sacred space
a place for prayer
worship and
adoration
A place to behold Christ
the revelation of God
the heartbeat of creation
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace
to find you
to envelop you
Commend your heart
And may we all come home
Thank You Johnny
We're going to start with Proud and Stable tonight
and the words of this song have always felt so authentic and true for our community and the values that we hold here
So hope you guys can join in if you know it or if not, just enjoy it
as we sing together
You can hold my hand
When you need to let go
I can be your mountain
When you're feeling down and low
I can be your stream that's
showing you the way home
You can hold my hand
When you need to let go
Oh I want a house
With a crown in my hand
I can be your mountain
When you need to let go
I can be your stream that's
showing you the way home
You can hold my hand
With a crown and table
And a place
By the fire
For everyone
Let us take
On the world
While we're young
And able
And bring us back
Together
When the day
Is done
If we want a garden
We're gonna have to
Sow the seeds
Plant a little
Happiness
Let the roots
Root
If it's love
That we give
Then it's love that we
Feed
If we want a garden
We're gonna have to sow the seeds
Oh I
Want a house
With a crown
And a table
And a place
By the fire
For everyone
Let us take
On the world
While we're young
And able
And bring us back
Together
When the day
Is done
The door is always
Open
On my walls
Everyone's a little broken
And everyone
Belongs
Yes everyone
Oh I
Want a house
With a crown and table
And a place
By the fire
For everyone
Let us take
On the world
While we're young and able
And bring us back
Together
When the day
Is done
And bring us back
Together
When the day
Is done
Oh
oh
Loud
Oh
You fooled me with your hands
Known and loved by you
Before I took a breath
When I doubted
Lord, remind me
I'm wonderfully made
You're an artist and a potter
I'm the canvas and the clay
You make all things
Work together
For my future
And for my good
You make all things
Work together
For your glory
And for your name
There's a healing light
Just beyond the cloud
Though I walk through fire
I see clearly now
I know nothing has been wasted
No failure or mistake
You're an artist and a potter
I'm the canvas and the clay
You make all things
Work together
For my future
And for my good
You make all things
Work together
For your glory
And for your name
You make all things
Work together
For my future
And for my good
You make all things
Work together
For your glory
And for your name
Oh, for your name
When I doubted
Lord, remind me
I'm wonderfully made
You're an artist and a potter
I'm the canvas and the clay
And I know nothing has been wasted
No failure or mistake
I know nothing has been wasted
You're an artist and a potter
I'm the canvas and the clay
And when I doubted
Lord, remind me
I'm wonderfully made
You're an artist and a potter
I'm the canvas and the clay
And I know nothing has been wasted
No failure or mistake
You're an artist and a potter
I'm the canvas and the clay
You're not finished with me
piano plays softly
She really rocked everything
And I will build my life
Upon your love
It is a firm foundation
And I will put my trust
In you alone
And I will not be shy
Let's sing that again
And I will build my life
Upon your love
It is a firm foundation
And I will put my trust
In you alone
And I will not be shaken
And I will build my life
Upon your love
It is a firm foundation
And I will put my trust
In you alone
And I will not be shaken
Oh
piano plays softly
In Ephesians 2 it says
His purpose was to create in himself
one new man out of two
thus making peace in this one body
to reconcile both of them to God
through the cross
by which he put to death
their hostility
He came and he preached peace
to you who were far away
and peace to those of you
who were near
for through him
through him we both have access
to the father by one spirit
cause you are no longer foreigners
no longer aliens
but fellow citizens
with God's people
members of his household
built on the foundation
of the apostles and the prophet
with Christ Jesus himself
as the chief cornerstone
in him the whole thing
is being built and joined together
and rises to become
a holy temple in the Lord
and in him you too
are being built together
to become a dwelling
in which God lives
by his spirit
God would you continue
to build us together tonight
would you be our peace
worthy of every song
we could ever sing
worthy of all the praise
we could ever bring
worthy of every breath
we could ever breathe
we live for you
oh oh oh
Jesus the name
above every other name
Jesus the only one
who could ever say
worthy of every breath
we could ever breathe
we live for you
Sing holy
and holy
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes
in wonder
and show me
who you are
and fill me
with your heart
and lead me
in your love
to those around me
oh oh oh
worthy
worthy of every song
we could ever sing
worthy of all the praise
we could ever bring
worthy of every breath
we could ever breathe
we live for you
Jesus
Jesus the name
above every other name
Jesus the only one
who could ever sing
worthy of every breath
we could ever breathe
we live for you
and holy
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes
in wonder
and show me
who you are
and fill me
with your heart
and lead me
in your love
to those around me
hey
oh oh oh
and I will build my life
upon your love
it is a firm foundation
and I will put my trust
in you alone
and I will not be shaken
and I will build my life
upon your love
it is a firm foundation
and I will put my trust
in you alone
and I will not be shaken
and holy
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes
in wonder
and show me
who you are
and fill me
with your heart
and lead me
in your love
to those around me
hey
lead us by your love
God we trust that your spirit who has come
and taken away every barrier
every dividing wall
every hostility
every division
we trust that you will continue
to weave into us as one body
your peace
your goodness
your faithfulness
God that our lives would be built
on something unlike the rest of the world
that we would carry with us
out of these doors
a faith that is greater
than the sorrow around us
a light that shines in darkness
a trust
that there is a firm foundation
that we can stand on
one that is love
one that made space and room
for each one of us
all of our stories
our baggage
our mistakes
you came and you made room
you invited us to your table
you called us sons and daughters
God when we hear that voice
continue to call us
continue to bring us back home
we love you Jesus
we trust you because you are good
you are love
you are our peace
it's in Jesus name that we pray all these things
amen
thank you guys
can you turn to the person beside you
and tell them the peace of Christ be with you
and then you can be seated
grace and peace
good to be with you all
it's so good
and a joy to welcome you
into this space
and as always that includes
joining us online
not forgotten
glad you could be with us
in that way
and yeah
just it's good to gather together
on this Sunday evening
so we are in part two
in our series right now
titled no fear in love
a study of first John
and we're taking five weeks
to kind of delve into this
this wonderful book of the Bible
and so we kicked off the series
last week
no worries though if you missed it
you can catch it on the pod
and also you know each message
is like a standalone
so you're not like you know
going to be lost or something
and so the title of my message
this week though is
where's the fire
and our primary text is
first John chapter 2
verses 3 through 6
and it says this
we know
that we've come to know him
if we keep his commands
whoever says I know him
but does not do what he commands
commands is a liar
and the truth is not in that person
but if anyone obeys his word
love for God is truly made complete
in them
and this is how we know
we are in him
whoever claims to live in him
must live as Jesus did
so there's kind of echoes here
of the teachings of Christ himself
notice is it kind of cutting out
so I'm going to go ahead
and switch over to the handheld
so there's kind of echoes here
of the teachings of Christ himself
where he says for example
in John 14-15
if you love me
keep my commands
or another one is
why do you call me Lord, Lord
and do not do what I say
or this passage comes actually
at the end of the sermon on the mountain
so it's like three chapters
of just him teaching
and teaching and teaching
and it's all the famous stuff
about love your enemies
and pray for those who persecute you
and it's like his greatest hits
and then he says
at the very end of that
verse 7
or chapter 7 of Matthew
verse 24
therefore everyone who hears
these words of mine
and puts them into practice
is like a wise man
in his house on the rock
so
kind of what I'm driving at here is
this is
or this isn't like John
kind of going off
on his own
this is like very much
kind of driving with the teachings
of Christ
he's very much kind of building
and expanding on
this tradition and angle
and of course you could kind of hear
in this
a rather somber
message in a way
of something like
you better perform
you better live up to God's
standards
but I don't think that's the spirit
of this passage
instead I think really
what Jesus and John are
I think what they have in mind
or what they're concerned about
is the very
kind of real temptation
particularly in
religious communities
where in essence we
we lose sight
of the end point
the goal, the aim, the purpose
of what we're doing
and it's amazing how this can happen
and honestly this happens just in life in general
it's like institutions
and communities of all sorts
start off with a certain aim
and we're all kind of gathered there
and before you know it
it's like other stuff is now
the kind of goal or purpose
or aim, it's like the original intent
and now we're crowded out by other fears
or anxieties or concerns
it's just amazing how this
happens and we end up losing
our way
and in essence
you might say that
in a Christian community
our goal here, the end point
of all of our prayers and worship and liturgy
and community and acts of service
what is it? I would say it's something like this
the goal of the Christian life is to become
people saturated
with God's great love
and I think this is really key
to remember
because there's a lot of verses in the Bible
and there's a lot of theology
and we can get off on all sorts of
weird tangents. Paul gives
of course a kind of poetic description of this in 1 Corinthians
chapter 13 verses 4-8
where he describes
love and just says love is patient
it's kind, it does not envy
it does not boast, it is not proud
it does not dishonor others
it is not self-seeking, it is not
easily angered, it keeps no record of wrongs
love does not delight in evil
but rejoices with the
truth. So it's like this
is the heart
of so much of the Christian
faith, this is what we're to be
about and you
can see though where this is
kind of a, it's like a shift or it's a change
in certain people's mind, it kind of
upends in a lot of ways our definition
of success and if you
kind of contrast this with
the broader society
it almost sounds like an insane goal, you're like
what's the purpose of your life? To become
saturated by God's love
for every person, every being
every creature, it would just be like
weird, this is just not
what we're about. I think of the broader world
in a lot of ways we're pretty much a society
kind of built around
something like money making, that's kind of
like career is everything, career is honestly identity
for a lot of people and that's
sort of the purpose
and so you're a success if
your net worth goes up
and you're not so much a success
it trends down. Or
even in the church though, certain versions
of Christianity have
different versions of what success looks
like. So one person might say
do I have more bible verses memorized
today than ten years ago or
do I understand Christian theology
better today than ten years
ago or did I attend
church every Sunday I was in town
for the last ten years or have I read the
complete works of, fill in your favorite
Christian author, Max Lucado
or Richard Rohr or whoever, have I
taken in all that
education or something, well okay
and what I want to name
is those can all be, that's good
it's a very
different thing to ask
kind of keying off of 1 Corinthians 13
have I grown more
patient in the last ten years?
You know what I mean?
And it's amazing how we go
to church, do all the things
and yet it's like
is it working?
What are we doing?
Or
another one might be am I more
self-centered or less
self-centered now
than like ten years ago. Do I
forgive more easily
keeping no record of wrongs
as Paul said love does
or do I just still
bear grudges like the absolute
same as I always
have. I think
this is what Jesus
and John are getting
at. The point
is the living and
the loving and if
we're living into that, well great
and if we're not
well then we're off track
no matter
how kind of spiritual
we might consider
ourselves to be. So
tonight what I want to do is unpack a few
of that kind of big idea and unpack a few
implications of
this. So the
first implication. Participating
in the religious tradition called
Christianity.
It's liturgies, it's holy days, it's rhythms
of fasting and prayer and so on and so forth.
It does not automatically place
one within
Christ. These
you might call them, they're like bread crumbs
leading us
nudging us, drawing us towards
the way of great love
and yet as Jesus said few
seem to find them.
And by the way when I say in Christ
I'm not thinking so much here like
in the tribe of people going
to heaven. I'm thinking
more of what Jesus
said are the most important things.
Loving God, loving other people.
And
I think
that's right, that's the
heart of this thing. So
in a ways we've kind of, I've already hinted
at this first point. So I'll
move on to the second one.
Implication number two. Before we read
it let me read verses five and six
of 1 John 2.
If anyone obeys his
word, love for God is truly
made complete in them.
And this is how we know we are in him.
Whoever claims to live in him
must live as Jesus did.
Second
implication. To participate
in a non-Christian religious tradition
does not automatically place
one outside of
the God who is love.
In fact all who long
to live in the way of great love
whether I believe they have the correct
doctrines or verbiage or image of God
or not can in fact be
in him.
I'm getting this from
John's language of
if anyone obeys
his word.
And I presume anyone means anyone.
I remember being
quite young
and
being raised
in a fairly conservative Christian environment.
There were a lot of adults
around me who were a bit
almost like
a little bit threatened by
insecure of
people in other religious
traditions who were
pretty clearly
very good hearted.
And this was a bit of a problem for us.
It was like
well, they're not
supposed to be.
This can't be
right because they don't have
the truth.
And there's even like some
elaborate theology we would do
around well
they're not really good.
It only appears to be good
externally but really
deep down it's not good because it's not motivated
by the right thing.
No, I think they're just kind of being kind.
And for example, I remember one little
moment in particular. It was like this random car ride
with a few of us
friends in the car
and the mother is of course driving us.
And there was
she was telling a story
about there was like a
Mormon family
and they had kind of been working to care for
another family who was
going through this really hard time of illness or something.
And I remember this
mother saying, even though
it was just us in the car, but she was almost kind of
whispering. She said some of the effect
of like, I don't care what they
say. Those Mormon people are
very, very nice.
It was like she was
kind of saying this kind of
like she's being edgy.
You can see where we get kind of weird
with this.
It's like we
kind of end up imagining people as utterly
cut off from
the spirit of God
or something. You know what I mean?
God's only found here
as opposed
to in a number
of different traditions.
In a similar
way, I remember being quite
shocked. I was trying to kind of
branch out pretty early on in my deconstruction
journey, and I was trying to branch out a little bit and
read some other religious traditions, but this made me very,
very nervous.
I don't know
why. In retrospect, it's
a little bit funny, but in the moment, it was like really
you know, I was like
edging out there. And so I remember
picking up my first biography of
the Buddha. And I was not
sure what I was going to find
in these pages. I don't know. He seemed
very nice sitting there in those
lotus postures or whatever, but I just
wasn't sure. You know what I mean? And so I start
reading, and
I was just
so surprised. I kept coming across quotes
like this. This is just one example.
Just as a mother would protect
with her life her own son, her only son,
so one should cultivate an
unbounded mind towards all beings
and loving kindness towards all
the world.
You know, I'm like,
so this is what I was so nervous about?
This is the problem? This is the
pagan teaching?
Yeah. I think another
example. Years ago, I
visited an Islamic mosque
to attend one of their
prayer
times.
And, you know,
of course, the whole service, it's in Arabic,
and all
very
strange to my
Christian ears.
It was like a whole new cultural environment,
and everything's
different, and even the
tonality of the prayers and such, and the
call to worship, it was just very different.
And again, I couldn't even really understand what they were saying,
so my mind
was just kind of running amuck
with all sorts of, I wonder
what are they saying?
What are they praying?
What is going on?
I was kind of curious, and it was interesting to be there,
but I was also very, if I'm honest,
nervous.
So later, I looked up
an English translation of the service,
of the prayers.
It was things like this.
All compliments, prayers, and beautiful expressions are for God.
Peace be on you, oh messenger,
and God's mercy and blessings.
Peace be on us, and on all righteous
servants of God.
Just like,
yeah?
Makes sense.
This is where I think
it's so easy to imagine people
as so different, so
distant, so
out there, when the truth
is I think
God finds all of us in a lot of ways.
Now my point in naming this isn't to say
all religious traditions are
the exact same, or all the doctrines
agree in every single way.
They do not.
And yet, what I want to communicate
here is a kind of vision of what's called
Christian inclusivism.
Which, by the way, goes way back in Christian history.
One of the earliest Christian theologians
was named Justin.
And he has a passage,
actually where he's kind of a commentary, where he's commenting
on this passage from John.
And he names
Jews and Muslims
as people
who may be obeying this word
kind of in their own way.
It's interesting. So you can see where Christians
have been thinking these thoughts and wrestling with
these ideas for
many thousands of years.
So, in essence,
this is what's called Christian
inclusivism, which says that
anyone, regardless of their exact religious tradition,
who is being
sensitive to the spirit and is being
guided on the path of great love.
Well, in fact, they are our brother, our sister,
our cousin, our sibling,
on the path.
Alright. Implication number
three.
Participating in the religious tradition
called my journey of deconstruction
or my personal spirituality
could
equally be an exercise
in missing the point
if it doesn't lead to a
transformative love.
What I'm getting at here
is, in essence,
if it's true
that this deepening
of love is
absolutely
essential, like it is
the main thing,
then, you know,
even after all of my reading
and my processing
and my,
you know, even
engaging with therapy and my
questioning,
what can happen,
I'm not saying this does, of course, but what can happen
is I might go through all of that
and yet
still end up
further
from the God who is
love.
In fact, you know, I'll say
I've seen this
happen in folks
and, honestly, I feel the temptation
of this in my own
kind of heart and mind,
my own
ego. I think in a lot of ways
there's a kind of
temptation towards
becoming, in essence, more
egocentric, you might say.
Does this make sense?
Maybe it's
like, in essence,
now,
this is definitely one I feel,
I now have
a story
about how
much more
kind of theologically
and spiritually
enlightened and advanced
I am, as opposed
to all of those
normal Christians.
Does that make sense?
You can see where this
becomes such
a tremendous
danger.
Where, in essence, we can just start to
feel so smart
and good about
ourselves and even begin to look
down with kind of, you know,
disdain on all those
unenlightened people.
Not realizing
that what happened,
that in essence, if
ego is the very thing tripping them up
in their own ways, and that's what's amazing.
We can see it in others
so clearly.
We can see it in other traditions
and those we, you know what I mean?
We can see where this
kind of,
yeah, this ego's coming and is messing everything
up. It's amazing, though, how in that
moment of that kind of distancing
and that judgment, it's like ego just
slips right in the back door
and suddenly, there I
am, you know, kind of
wagging my finger at those people
from my own
kind of high horse
and such.
In essence, how do I know that there's something wrong
going on there?
It's when I
can sense that I have a
total and complete and utter lack
of love for them.
That's when you
know.
That's when you know, like,
uh-oh.
Have I read so much theology
and done all the things
and yet,
here I am
further away from the God
who is love than when I
began, because my own heart's
getting so
perhaps angry
or cold or something
towards them.
I just think this is something to be
constantly aware of
because, yes, of
course, there is much to critique
in these other versions and
wings of the church, which we
talk about
a lot.
And yet, at the same
time, I think it's so true that there's
a grave temptation for us to be filled
with
a certain pride.
Oh, God, I thank you that I'm not like
those other Christians.
Which just
echoes there of a certain key New Testament
story.
And that's problematic.
So, in other words, the point
of, when I think of
deconstructing and such, the whole point
is to tear down
every idol
that is hindering us
from
becoming more
open-hearted,
more compassionate.
And that even
includes the work
and the journey
to
forgive
those who have hurt us.
Former churches, church leaders,
even family members
and such.
The spiritual teacher, Ram Dass,
he said, if you think you're so enlightened,
go and spend a week with your
parents.
I would say this is
the gold standard of spiritual maturity
in a lot of ways, you know.
I want to close with this. This is a rather
lengthy story, but it's
from a Jesuit
priest. Which is interesting, as you
hear the story, to know it was written by
a Catholic priest.
But his
name is Anthony DeMello, and
he's written one wonderful book in particular
I love, is Awareness.
So, so good. But
he tells this story, and it's one of those
stories you hear once and it just kind of continues to work
on you, so it just continued to challenge and disturb
me, so I wanted to
close out and share it with all of
you. So the story goes like
this. There was a man
who invented the art of
making fire.
So he went up to the snow-clad
northern regions,
where the hill tribes were
shivering in the cold,
and he began to teach them
the art and advantages of
making fire. He showed them
the value of being able to be
warm in the winter, and how to
cook their food, and
how it can help you make bricks
and then build buildings and such. And they learned
all this very enthusiastically.
They're so grateful they learned this art
of making fire.
And yet before they could express their gratitude,
he just quietly slipped
away. He didn't even
give them time to thank him. He was just one of those rare human
beings endowed with a certain greatness.
They're not bothered with being
remembered or being thanked.
They just want your good.
And so he went on from there
to another tribe, and then another, all the while
teaching the people to make fire.
They were so enthusiastic.
He began to get more and more popular.
The priests
feared that their own popularity
would diminish.
And so they decided
to get rid
of him by poisoning
him, which
they unfortunately did.
And yet, a
suspicion arose among the people
that it was in fact
the priests who had
done it.
So you know what the priests did?
They had a portrait of
the great inventor
enthroned upon the main
altar of the temple,
and a liturgy designed
so that his name would be revered
and his memory kept alive.
The greatest care
was taken that not a single
rubric of the liturgy was altered
or omitted. The tools
for making fire were enshrined
within a casket and were said
to bring healing to all who laid
their hands on them with faith.
The high priest
himself undertook the task of compiling
a life of the inventor.
This became the holy book
in which the inventor's
loving kindness was offered as an
example for all to emulate.
His glorious deeds were eulogized.
His superhuman nature made an article
of faith.
The priests saw to it that the book was handed down
to future generations.
While they authoritatively interpreted
the meaning
of his words and the significance of his
holy life and death,
and they punished with death or
excommunication anyone who deviated
from their doctrine.
Caught up as they were in these
religious tasks, the people
completely forgot the art of
making fire.
The veneration,
the worship, the ritual
were faithfully
observed and went on decade
after decade, century after
century.
But there was no fire.
Ritual, remembrance,
gratitude, veneration,
goodwill, yes.
But no fire.
DeMello
concludes by saying this,
the best religion in the world
is the religion called love.
Not the religion
called Lord, Lord.
Who
says this thing about
love? Jesus Christ himself.
DeMello says this is what
Christ is all about, but
we overemphasized the Lord,
Lord, didn't we?
Where's the fire?
And if the worship isn't leading
to the fire, and if adoration
isn't leading to love,
if the liturgy
isn't leading to a clearer perception
of reality, if God isn't
leading to life
of what uses religion
except to create more division,
more fanaticism,
more antagonism.
It is not from a lack
of religion in the ordinary sense of the word
that the world is suffering.
It is from a lack
of love.
In the name of the Father, the Son,
and the Holy Spirit, Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal
with his disciples,
and at that meal, he held a
loaf of bread, and he broke it.
He said, take it, eat.
This is my body. It's broken for you.
And he held up a cup of wine.
He said, take it, drink.
This is my blood. It's shed for you.
Whenever you eat this bread,
whenever you drink this cup,
remember me.
And so as we come to the table,
we seek
not only to connect with Christ,
but we pray to be filled with his great love
so we can walk out those doors
and actually live
the way Christ is inviting us
to live.
So the way we'll take communion tonight,
we'll just go row by row, starting here at the front
and forming one line here in the middle.
We practice an open table,
so if you're here tonight and you want to participate,
you're free to do that, regardless of your
denomination or theology.
You can come to this table.
Just know the red is wine, the white is grape juice,
and you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like.
So this is the table.
Not of the church,
but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come.
You who have much faith and you who have little,
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long,
you who have tried to follow
and you who feel like you've failed,
come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you.
And it's his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here.
Come to the table.
Come.
.